I want you to listen and try to guess
who or what this is
ultrasound recorded above your hearing
range but slowed down so you could hear
so that was an advertisement call from
the peak of The Mating Season scientists
can decode these calls so let's sample
back to English translation would be pay
attention I'm a pipest trellis natuzibat
specifically male my name is X I am
Landing here and we share a common
social identity and common communication
pool for a pickup line by about not bad
scientists have recorded millions of bad
vocalizations like this and they've
decoded many of them using Ai and
they've revealed that bats have dialects
that they pass down from one generation
to the next and that baby bats learn to
speak just like you did by listening to
the adults around them and babbling back
until they speak adult bat